so you're able to say you were wrong
yeah it's just when you're talking it's
very vague so I'm just trying to make it
more specific yeah I'll give them the
safe space to know that we can have
those conversations where they can call
me out or I can call them out and we
couldn't come to a conclusion so you'll
say to him I'll admit when I'm wrong
yeah okay so that's the safe space as
you'll admit as long as I have that back
in return for me to feel yeah yeah okay
but you won't do that unless he says I
was wrong too I will do that but I'd
expect it back every time I worded that
so incorrectly my bad
um so that
um I'm very very very passionate
um I'm fun so I don't think anyone can
record around me when they know me